local artist ellie rush is getting a  four-year scholarship to unlv she won an  art contest held by the university and  the cosmopolitan the prompt for the  contest was diversity she created a  piece she calls refractions inspired by  the details of that massive chandelier  inside the cosmo  i figured that's really similar to  people how people are all unique in  their own special ways but they do have  ways that they're  they share commonalities with each other  but i wanted to really communicate that  idea through this piece  well she certainly did it's a gorgeous  piece the hand-painted mural went up in  a spot where it can be the first thing  that employees see when they come to  work and congratulations on that  scholarship